hello good evening and welcome to the
take with Sophie Ridge live at nine here
in the heart of Westminster now the
first flights carrying British Nationals
evacuated from Sudan have landed in the
UK but there are thousands more people
waiting to escape and the situation in
Sudan raises questions about how to deal
with people fleeing danger around the
world just as a government's illegal
migration Bill designed to stop small
boats crossing the channel passes in the
House of Commons a government Minister
tonight tells this program it's testing
the limits of international law so
plenty to get in stuck into as we bring
you takes from all sides over the next
60 minutes
the eyes to the right 289 the nose to
the left 230.
well that was the government's illegal
migration legislation passing its final
Commons hurdle this evening and earlier
on things got pretty heated and actually
quite personal as the two major Party
leaders clashed at pmqs
if he has any actual ideas for the
economy he should say so because all I
hear from the party opposite it's more
spending more borrowing higher inflation
higher interest rates it's the same old
labor party
and there wasn't much quarter given by
kirstama either
this is Mr 24 tax Rises
I've never heard anything so out of
touch as the answer that he has just
given he could stop the handouts he's
giving to oil and gas giants he could
scrap his beloved non-dom status I think
you can really tell that there might be
the local elections around the corner
from that exchange don't you think we've
got some top guests on the program this
evening as well including the minister
for Africa Andrew Mitchell
for the labor party we're going to be
talking to Labor's Shadow International
Trade secretary Nick Thomas Simmons plus
we'll be talking to the conservative MP
who won concessions from the government
on that illegal migration bill that is
Tim Lawton he'll be on the program as
well plus much more besides on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
now the government's illegal migration
Bill all part of Russia cnx pledged to
stop the boats has passed the commons
and is on the way to the Lords but there
were some dissent from the likes of
Theresa May in Duncan Smith and Jeffrey
Cox on the conservative benches well
let's crack straight on we can start
with the best bits of the week so far
hello good morning the UK government has
announced that an operation is underway
for evacuation flights for British
Nationals stuck in Sudan the first one
was sort of middle of the evening
yesterday there was one in the early
hours of this morning and essentially uh
asked people if they feel comfortable to
make their own way to the Airfield we
don't really have any other way to get
them there ourselves I'm encouraged that
both factions have called a 72-hour
ceasefire that of course we cannot be
sure for how long it will hold you just
think to yourself
should I have left should I have stayed
behind
it just angers me so much that
beautiful Sudan with its Beautiful
People is being
governed by boys with very dangerous
toys
now the government's illegal immigration
Bill returns to Parliament today with
MPS expected to vote on amendments to
the bill this evening we need to deter
people from making the journey in the
first place that's why I encourage
everybody to get behind our measures the
United Kingdom like many countries Works
closely with the unhcr and we already
operate safe and legal routes in
partnership with them last couple of
minutes Theresa May who has an amendment
down to protect victims of modern
slavery from this bill has made a very
angry speech government Amendment 95 is
an example of good faith I would say
rather it's a slap in the face of those
of us who actually care about the
victims of modern slavery and human
trafficking prime minister is on his
feet he talks about this London thing I
think he's already spent the money that
he claims he'd raised on five different
things this is Mr 24 tax Rises
and I've never heard anything so out of
touch does he really think that
everything's fine or is he just clueless
about life outside of his bubble
[Applause]
a really livey day in House of Commons
as you can see from that we can start
this evening with the government's
response to that crisis in Sudan and the
news that evacuated Brits have started
arriving in the UK a little earlier I
spoke to the development and Africa
Minister Andrew Mitchell at the foreign
office
thank you very much for being on program
and what's the latest update you can
give us on the evacuation of British
Nationals from Sudan well so far so good
it's going very smoothly we've had about
300 out today four flights there's no
Log Jam at the airport the message to
the British Nationals who want to leave
is come to the airport there's no great
backlog no great congestion and we're
taking people out in a steady Manner and
we want them all to come if they want to
leave and as you know we are urging them
to do so if they if they are eligible
they should come as soon as they can you
say it's gone smoothly and some people
say they've been stranded there's been
others saying there's been Anarchy
there's been violence that there should
have been escorts to help people get to
the airport safely how can you say
something smoothly well I mean in terms
of getting to the airport we adopted
exactly the same uh route as the Germans
did the Germans told people they needed
to get themselves to the airport and
then they would be taken out and we've
done exactly the same thing and people
have been coming to the airport and as I
say 300 to today there's there's a small
queue but not a large queue the Border
Force Hub processing people it's all
going relatively smoothly I mean there
are of course there are problems and in
these sort of situations uh that the
news isn't always accurate but what I
can tell you for certain tonight is that
about 300 people have already come out
will be more I think by the end of the
day and four flights have left
you say that people should continue to
come to the airport are you prepared to
stay until everyone who wants to get
there has managed to reach it we are ABS
we are absolutely in the hands of the
ceasefire so far more or less this
ceasefire has held this is the second
day of a three-day ceasefire we are
doing everything we can to make sure
it's prolonged and on The Wider stage
too trying to negotiate for a longer
ceasefire because if the combatants
don't lay down their arms and return to
Barracks there is going to be a
humanitarian catastrophe in Sudan but as
far as the British citizens are
concerned we are getting them out
there's a steady flow if you want to go
please come to the airport did you
reviews after the evacuation in
Afghanistan did you learn any lessons
from that we learned an enormous number
of lessons from that and those lessons
have been implemented like what kind of
things well the crisis center that is
working seamlessly across government 24
7 since the crisis broke processing
dealing with everything we are following
every single conceivable opportunity but
remember that Afghanistan was very uh
different and in some way this is worse
than that because we don't have troops
on the ground we don't control the
airport like we did in Afghanistan and
we don't have a permissive environment
Khartoum airport is is not working got
no planes can land or take off and of
course there's not a permissive
environment we had the permission of the
Taliban to leave from Kabul this is a
ceasefire and it can break down and you
we're talking about the British
Nationals who can leave
of course in Sudan there's many other
people who can't leave right because
they live there what are we doing to
help them well there's 16 million people
already who are on humanitarian relief
help with food and also with other
humanitarian support
they that's before this crisis started
and as a result of this crisis the
humanitarian agencies have had to take
their people out five humanitarian
workers have died and so the situation
is even worse it's not just that there's
a greater humanitarian crisis it's that
the humanitarian Community I'm not there
to help them so so that is why having a
ceasefire is absolutely essential and we
know you as someone who believes in
international age you help believe in
helping the poorest people in the world
the most vulnerable people in the world
because obviously it's the right thing
to do to help them but also I guess
there's a soft power there you you would
you can intervene earlier to try and
mean that you can shape the situation if
you like
Aid to Sudan halved recently 142 million
in 2020 to 2021 to 62 million in 21 to
22. these things have consequences don't
they well if you look at the position
over recent years we've spent something
like a quarter of a billion pounds there
in relief but you're looking at the
bilateral figures we we help in a whole
range of different ways through the
United Nations through the various
looking at the foreign
they are the they are the bilateral yes
they are but their aid from the UK to
Saddam yes but remember we support
people of Sudan through humanitarian
relief not only bilaterally but also
through un agencies so so the picture is
uh is is not quite as as those figures
would suggest because there's other
support that we give but but remember
that when there is a humanitarian crisis
we have a degree of flexibility as we've
shown in the Horn of Africa for example
so that we we can do more and I guess my
point is if you intervene earlier with
Aid I mean you believe this too right
you believe this if you intervene early
with Aid people argue that you don't
have to have the same full-blown
humanitarian crisis well the
humanitarian crises that occur that they
they can they can be mitigated in some
ways by by the sort of climate change
adaptation money that we spend which
means that the next time the same sort
of Crisis strikes uh then there is
greater resilience but remember this did
not start as a humanitarian crisis it
started because two generals were
slugging it out for control there's no
ideology involved here and there's no
weather conditions involved here it is
broken down because of the behavior of
these two generals but the point I'm
making is this that on a humanitarian
crisis we do have a degree of
flexibility and we exercise that as
crises arrive okay what are the safe and
legal routes for someone in Sudan to
claim asylum in the UK
well at the moment those safe and legal
routes don't exist but the prime
minister in the changes that we are
making as part of the legislation which
is going through the house tonight has
said that we will be seeking to set up
safe and legal routes there's a package
in order to stop the awful uh
cross-channel
um uh trade that has been perpetrated by
The People's Smugglers there's a package
there and it includes developing safe
and legal routes it includes a massive
Improvement in the relationship with the
French and it improves much quicker
processing in the UK so so the the prime
minister's package which we're
legislating for tonight is I think the
right package to deter people from
putting themselves into the hands of the
modern day equivalent of the slave
trader and a leaky boat and crossing the
channel so safe and legal routes to
Sudan will happen no I'm not saying that
what I'm saying is that the government
has made it clear that it will be trying
to as a result of this whole package all
the measures we're taking that we will
be looking to try and make sure the safe
and legal routes are set up I mean we
have no time scale for this we don't
know what countries they're gonna affect
we have no details on it
are you happy with that what well I
think I think there's a there's a it's
important to get it right there's a
there's a longer term plan which the
Prime Minister has uh brought in when he
looked at these the whole issue of the
boats Crossing uh the channel and
migration but to your earlier point I
will just point out that the development
budget International Development
spending which as you say I do believe
strongly and so do so do millions of
people in Britain it is designed to try
and build safer more prosperous
societies and countries over there so
that people don't feel the need to move
to the Richer world
um
I'm voting on the illegal migration Bill
about trying to stop small boats about
um sending people to Rwanda if they do
make that Crossing now the Home
Secretary says she can't say whether
it's compatible with the conventional
and human rights but she wants MPS to
vote for anyway I just want to read out
to you what Sir Jeffrey Cox the
conservative MP said he said the
government is in fact asking this house
to give legislative sanction to at least
the possibility that a minister of the
crown will deliberately disobey the
international law obligations of this
country what would you say to your
colleague
well I think that we are testing the
limits of the convention and uh we're
not the first government to do so labor
did it as well on one occasion we're
testing the limits and we must see what
happens as a result of that testing
testing the limits of international law
we are yes we are and the government's
been quite open about that because the
law the law as uh it operates at the
moment and in particular the conventions
uh the migration conventions are quite
dated I think they do need to be updated
but it's a very difficult thing to do
because you have to have uh agreement
across all countries so I do think they
are they are needing to be tested and
that's what the government will be doing
uh so Jeffrey Cox says MPS are being
able to ask to approve quite consciously
and deliberately a deliberate breach of
our obligations under the ech are your
lawmakers
he says you're breaching the law you say
you're testing the limits of the law
well if you look at the response from
Robert generic at the dispatch box he
wouldn't accept that but what I'm saying
to you is that we know that we are
testing the frontiers of the law here
we've been quite open about that as the
government properly should be it is
because circumstances are so changed
since these laws were first brought in I
mean
let's see where it lands testing the
frontiers of the law sounds like you're
doing some like great big Grand gesture
like space exploration or something when
actually other people would say look
let's call a spade a spade you're
breaching the law what uh Sir Jeffrey
Cox is a very eminent lawyer and former
Minister Robert generick is also a very
eminent lawyer and he does not agree
with sir Jeffrey's analysis so I can't
give you an answer on that legal
argument tonight but I can tell you what
the reason the government is doing this
is to try and resolve an intolerable
situation where people are putting
themselves in leaky boats trying to
cross one of the biggest busiest
shipping lanes in the world it's
extremely dangerous and it's wrong and
we're trying to stop it okay okay thank
you very much
testing the frontiers of international
law according to the development and
Africa Minister Andrew Mitchell I'm sure
this won't be the end of that story if
the courts have anything to do with it
as well there'll be more on the crisis
on Sudan and also the evacuation of
Britain's from the country throughout
the evening here on Sky News and some of
the interviews we're doing later as well
but I just want to talk to you about
politics in the UK because it's just
eight days until a set of local
elections across England that are really
crucial test for both Rishi sunak and
kirstalmer so we can take a bit of a
closer look now with our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates about these
elections I have to say I I mean I'm a
bit geeky when it comes to politics but
I'm really excited about these elections
I feel like it is a really big test for
Rishi sunak of course but also kierstama
you know can he convert the big poll
lead into results at The Ballot Box what
are you going to be looking out for
absolutely Sophie I think and I'm biased
that you should be excited because a
week tomorrow large parts of the country
go to the pods for the last time in
local elections before a general
election probably going to be next year
I think it matters for a couple of
reasons first of all this is the first
electoral test for issue so that since
he became prime minister and also
everybody's looking to see whether
kierstama has the momentum that he's uh
can translate the momentum that he's had
in the last year into The Ballot Box so
let's look first of all at where there
are elections because that's actually
pretty critical now 8 100 seats and 230
different councils but the first thing
you'll notice is that this map of the
United king is all chopped up because
there are no elections in Scotland there
are no elections in Wales there aren't
elections in Northern Ireland but uh now
but they will be on May the 18th that's
because they didn't think they could get
all the counting out of the way uh
before the coronation and some parts
countries like London uh no elections uh
as well so you see the kind of broad uh
all different types of councils up for
election metropolitans Borough councils
so a real mix and a real test of
different type of politics uh up and
down the country now when counting
begins at 10 o'clock on Thursday night
you're also the different ways that you
can measure how the parties have done
are we looking uh very carefully at all
sorts of them now
some politicians often the ones that are
doing less well will tell you there is
no relationship between local elections
and a general election there's some
evidence you can point to but but just
look at this you could this what this is
is it's the number of overall number of
counselors uh that there are uh uh in
all the different local elections that
are going back to 1990. and look at this
just before the 1997 labor Landslide
what you could see is that labor did win
uh the highest number of councils with
the with the Tories dropping right back
down then just before David Cameron went
into uh Downing Street there the Tories
had taken over control of local
government really with labor in the
doldrums you can see that line
punishment of the for the lib Dems of
going into Coalition and this is where
we're sort of this is where we left off
last year but the conservatives just
ahead of um the labor party so the
moment you look at this you can see one
very uh clear possible outcome which is
if labor are doing well maybe these
loans will cross and labor will become
the largest part of local government
that's one of the things that we're
going to look at now let's look at the
seats position at the moment as left
last year the conservatives have 300
3656 labor have two thousand uh 131 lib
Dems
1223 now everybody watches this guy will
know Michael Thrasher he's uh our
election analyst uh a great voice uh we
rely on his work uh now he says that in
a bad night for the conservatives is
entirely possible it's a little bit
harder than my finger that the
conservatives lose a thousand seats
a big big number now funnily enough
sitting in front of you conservatives
agree with that Greg hands uh was saying
as much uh on Sunday now labor if they
are performing as well the polls could
put on 700 seats but funnily enough you
won't get a labor spokesman to say any
of that
uh so you can kind of see this kind of
ballpark of what would be a bad and a
good night for both parties but at the
moment what you have with councils is
some are controlled by one party and
some are in no overall control but the
party with the largest number of
councils up for grabs the overall
control is the conservatives now look at
this look at how easy it'll seem uh for
the conservatives PG doing badly because
in all of these seats if the
conservatives lose just one seat on the
council they go Canterbury chair Will
Made made some Theresa May's backyard uh
Stratford Bonnet they lose two seats all
of these go and you know some of these
uh are pretty staunch as Brandon Lewis's
backyard Great Yarmouth uh well when
Hatfield lose three and key parts of the
red wall uh and the North and the
Midlands Amber Valley uh air wash
uh uh you can see uh going so it's quite
easy for the conservatives to look like
they're having a bad night but another
way that you can look at uh General uh
local elections is by the share of the
vote so at the end of the process when
all the votes have been counted Michael
Thrasher will calculate the percentage
uh that uh voted for the conservative
the percentage that basically labor the
percentage that voted for lib Dems and
other and the question will be are they
did they do as well as the polls suggest
so at the moment there's pretty much a
15 percentage Point Gap a lead for the
labor party now the question is is it
gonna be anything like that because
traditionally in local elections
actually labor haven't done quite as
well they haven't got quite as high uh a
share of the vote last year Michael
Thrasher calculated that the labor party
got 35 percentage points quite a bit
down on where they are at the moment and
the Tory party got uh 33 which quite a
lot less than there at the moment so the
question is is the conservative pass is
the labor party going to go up from that
um from that figure and can we say that
that represents success a quick truck
around where we think uh is important
now labor will tell you that what
matters are the seats where they're
going to end up fighting in the general
election place like Swindon places like
Plymouth
actually what really matters to labor is
what's going to go on in the north and
we're going to be looking at places like
uh tees Valley uh Stockton and then in
the Midlands accounts we often talk
about with Derby which the last couple
of sets of local elections labeled
disastrously can they get a uh a
foothold back what the Tories say is
what they're really uh worried about is
the incursion of the liberal Democrats
in the South so areas like Surrey Heath
that's Michael Gove uh wokingham that's
John wedra places like that they're
worried that the lib Dems are getting a
toe help but what will really worry them
is if the Gap with the labor party
extends and that's what we're going to
be looking at that's how we're going to
focus on it we'll be there from 1001 on
Thursday night you me and the sky team
if you watch it's gonna be yeah it's
gonna be really interesting it's what
local elections you know all these
places that you could have never
necessarily hear of that suddenly
everyone starts focusing on Council
areas because it does start to give us a
bit of a overall picture on politics um
is Rishi sunak cutting through is he
holding on to the blue wall is he
Shoring up the conservative party is
kirstama speaking to the people that he
needs to do rather than just piling up
votes in areas that labor are already
strong uh Sam you're going to be there
Sam will be there overnight I'm going to
be there the next day trying to work out
the narrative and so full coverage of
the local elections are on Sky News all
our platforms as well social online from
election day next Thursday I definitely
want to watch you're watching the take
we are live in Westminster up next we
are going to be talking to Labor's
Shadow International Trade secretary
Nick Thomas Simmons
thank you
[Music]
I hope it makes you happy I really do
top person but you know what you won't
stop me because I'll just pick it all up
and I'll carry on okay I can't plant in
this section but I'll carry on you won't
stop me whatsoever
we've got a fence at the front and
there's a footprint well the police said
it's a hand print
um on the actual Banner at the front
where they've either climbed over or got
out
um and the salt was just everywhere it
was all over everywhere two days before
I'd been with the children oh one was
only five and one was seven so to have a
five-year-old sit for an hour and a half
Planting onions for someone else that's
why it hurt me so much
um what happened was we dug it all up
and we've moved it over to the like the
front of it so there's a massive Mound
but we're gonna get taken away it's
class is poisonous really you can't do
anything with it but what they didn't
think about is all the nature they
destroyed as well I mean this allotment
hadn't been used for eight years and the
worms in it were fat and chunky and we
were laughing about how big they are
they're not there anymore it's it's
mind-blowing you know I did all this on
nothing I got from eight foot brambles
to down here with nothing and now I have
this money and I can do so many things
to help our community I I just want to
make sure that every single penny is
used wisely and we're not just going oh
we can spend that on that we can spend
that on that no it's not going to be
like that we're going to make sure that
every penny is used to benefit the
community mainly root vegetables because
you can make strong decent meals out of
them yeah it's lovely to have lettuce
but it's not going to fill you up you
know it's a really good strong root
vegetables going in and ones where you
can chop and freeze and that will last
through the winter as well so I'm so
looking forward to it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you are watching the take well let's get
the take from labor now just a little
earlier I spoke to the parties Shelley
trade secretary Nick Thomas Simmons
let's listen
so Andrew Mitchell has said that the
evacuation process from Sudan is going
smoothly do you think it is
well I sincerely hope that it is we've
got this 72 hour window at the moment
with the ceasefire we really have to
have as a priority evacuating British
Nationals uh I understand though that an
evacuation Center has been set up we
have to do everything now that we
possibly can to make sure that all those
British Nationals come home and we make
that process as easy for them as
possible but then more widely we also
have to continue to push through
diplomatic channels to try to find and
end this Dreadful conflict
should open up more routes for people to
claim Asylum from countries like Sudan
well I think first of all with Sudan
we've got to work internationally to
look at neighboring countries because
clearly what we want to see is a
situation where the conflict is brought
to a conclusion and people can return to
their homes I think that has to be the
priority first of all
clearly there will be as well Sudanese
people here in the United Kingdom and
the government has to look at the
situation there may well be ongoing Visa
applications for example in terms of
family modes and the government really
does need to be looking at that as well
but the real priority has to be
internationally at this time
obviously we'd love to see a diplomatic
solution in Sudan right I think that
goes without saying
but you know realistically how much of a
role can the UK actually play in that
well we can actually do something is
take Asylum Seekers should we be doing
that
well firstly the UK still has quite
remarkable diplomatic clubs around the
world and that is something that I've
seen at firsthand the question is should
we be taking more Asylum Seekers from
Sudan well in terms of uh in terms of
that just to take that firstly I think
it has to be internationally first of
all that we do this it has to be an
international
solution where of course we should be
playing a part in that there is a wider
question too about resettlement schemes
we've run resettlement schemes
previously as to how they're working of
course we can look at that but the
priority at the moment has to be
internationally okay
um
obviously the Sudan situation is
happening at a time when you have also
been voting on the illegal migration
Bill and it does feel like these two
issues overlap we're talking about
people in need for Moses overseas should
we be taking in more Asylum Seekers
well I think we need to first of all
deal with the issue that we've got of
thousands of people who are risking
their lives in small boats in the
English Channel now I've been down to
Dover I've been in the past across to
France and seen it firsthand how
dangerous those sea lanes are now to
deal with this situation we need to do
in my view a number of things we
shouldn't be spending the money that's
being spent on the Rwanda scheme which
just a headline grabbing scheme we
should be using that money to set up a
specific sale in the National Crime
agency to try to deal with people
trafficking secondly we need to deal
with the Asylum backlog the Asylum
backlog is in the region about 138
000 the government just isn't dealing
with it I mean I've just voted in the
House of Commons for Fast Track
procedures in specific cases and the
government has just voted it down the
Asylum systems in Kirsten thirdly we
then need much better return agreements
the government hasn't negotiated a
successor scheme to what was called the
doubling three regulation the Dublin
three regulation both allowed us to
return people whose claims had failed to
other safe countries and also did
include a safe route that's what the
government now needs to do
so I've been listening like really
carefully to what you've been saying and
it really does strike me that labor talk
a lot about attacking the government
when it comes to competence so getting
rid of the backlog of claims which don't
get me wrong I can see why that's
something that people feel they should
be doing it's hard to disagree with that
but I guess what I'm trying to get to is
what labor undercused armor believes
when it comes to Asylum Seekers do you
believe that the UK should be taking
more Asylum Seekers well it will vary
once it year on year and what happens
here is people who come here and seek
Asylum what they actually should have is
a process that works very quickly for it
we decided where they've got a valid
claiming but that is a matter for the
courts I I can't sit in I think in any
other politician and tell you in a
particular year how many Asylum seeks
have valid claims and who don't that
doesn't matter for the court sure of
course I would never ask you to say
which particular people have valid
claims or not but I just think that
there is an overall question about what
labor believes when it comes to Asylum
Seekers do you think that we're taking
enough Asylum Seekers and I do think
that some politicians would be able to
give you an answer to that well the
number that we take will depend upon the
number of valid claims that there are
you sure and that's something for the
courts and in terms of let me just just
answer too because at the moment we have
a situation back in the early years of
this government in March 2011 the Asylum
backlog was probably just under about
six thousand it's now 138
000. should we be processing those
claims far more quickly so that we can
see those that have a genuine claim
who've always had a safe haven here and
those who do not have a valid claim that
need to be returned to save countries
absolutely we should be that's what I've
been trying to vote for in the House of
Commons that's where the government's
been failing um Andrew Mitchell said
that the legislation today is in his
words pushing the limits of
international law is it breaking
international law well the Home
Secretary in placing a certificate the
so-called section 19 certificate uh
under the human rights act on the bill
wasn't able to give a full assurance
that it followed International and that
is he and let me just say that that is a
profound error from this government
because I aspire to negotiate trade
deals around the world and that is
important for our prosperity and to do
that we have to be a country whose word
is believed that when we sign on the
dotted line for our International
obligations we are a country that is
going to stand by that in the years
ahead and this breaking uh International
we've heard it before of course when uh
the then Northern Ireland secretary
talks about breaking international law
in a limited and specific way that
damages us standing on the international
stage and ultimately will damage our
prosperity as well so just finally if
labor was in power would you overturn
this legislation
we will pass legislation that gives
effect to the principles that I set out
in the interview a moment or two ago
Sophie so that we can actually have a an
immigration system that is fair that's
what we will do okay thank you thank you
or that was the labor view on the
illegal immigration and Asylum seeking
situation up next on the take like the
Westminster of course we are going to be
looking at pmqs it was a really fiery
one as you'd expect at just a week or so
ahead of a local elections
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
were first started to go up against each
other at Prime Minister's questions and
they were kind of polite they were
almost trying to Rise Above The Fray
well that is now completely gone out of
the window because there were some
pretty personal exchanges over the cost
of living in particular between the
Prime Minister and the labor leader
earlier here's our political
correspondent Joe Pike with pmqs
unwrapped
even before Kia storm had asked his
first question Rishi sunak managed to
slip in a dig about Labor's position on
gender it was in response to this given
that the leader of the opposition
apparently doesn't know what a woman is
that he won't stand up to defend women
in his own party
[Applause]
this when he was in charge as DPP does
my right honorable friend think that the
labor party are in any position to teach
anyone about respect for women they
should work out the answer to one very
simple question I'm certain what a woman
is is he
the labor leader did not take the bait
and dodged that topic today Kiest armor
could have asked about the Sudan
evacuation or the Dominic Rob bullying
rail but instead he focused on the
economy and cost of living with some
thinly veiled attacks on the PM
including a repost to last week being
labeled Mr Softee
this is Mr 24 tax Rises
and I've never heard anything so out of
touch does he really think that
everything's fine or is he just clueless
about life outside of his bubble he
refuses to scrap the non-dom status that
benefits him and his family this I can
see why he's attracted to this non-dom
thing this prime minister is so removed
from the country that he boasted that he
didn't know a single working-class
person
[Applause]
those questions from secure did seem
shorter and sharper than usual but it
all got pretty personal while starma
painted sunac as out of touch sumac
argued starma is weak he talks about
this London thing I think he's already
spent the money that he claims he'd
raised on five different things the rank
hypocrisy of it on Monday in the other
place they decided to side with
extremist protesters just yesterday they
sided with polluters Mr Speaker
we're siding with the British people Mr
Speaker that's what the conservative
government does
perhaps no surprise we saw that tone of
debate with local elections now just
eight days away I mean while the snp's
leader made an effective point with
questions about UK immigration policy
can I ask the prime minister to outline
the safe and legal route available to a
child Refugee seeking to flee Sudan and
come to the United Kingdom now that he
has confirmed that there is no safe
illegal route will he therefore confirm
that it would be his government's
intention to detain and Deport a child
Refugee who flees Sudan and comes to the
United Kingdom this country has a proud
record of passionately supporting those
who need our assistance elsewhere the PM
gave a clear answer on paying
reparations for the UK's role in slavery
offer a full and meaningful apology for
our country's role in slavery and
colonialism and commit to reparatory
Justice no no Mr Speaker when asked by
an smpmp about Dominic Raab and bullying
Mr sunak nodded towards the ongoing
police investigation into SMP finances
it is somewhat odd to be getting
lectures on values right now from the
SNP
and the speaker got a little confused
introducing kirstama as if he was
running the country
so just be aware that somebody will be
going for that cup of tea today prime
minister
perhaps if opinion polls prove accurate
a sign of things to come
what we've been discussing this evening
the government's controversial new
migration legislation designed to try
and ensure those crossing the channel in
small boats are swiftly removed to a
third country like Rwanda well that
passed the commons today there was of
course lots of opposition from labor and
others but also some concerns from some
unconservative edges as well now we can
talk to you our next guest who won some
concessions from the government over
unaccompanied children Tim Lawton joins
us now thank you very much for being
with us so how did you vote today
I voted for the bill this bill needs to
go through because we have got to do
something practical to stop this
completely unsustainable and dangerous
business of small boats coming across
the the channel in a disorderly way and
it's tough there are really tough
measures in the in the bill to clamp
down on bogus assignment Seekers and on
the people Smugglers who are benefiting
from this this tragic trade and I wanted
to balance that with making sure that
there are clearly defined safe and legal
routes which was amendment that I put
down with a lot of colleagues which the
government has accepted so there will be
clearly set out safe legal routes for
genuine Sun Seekers to be able to come
to the UK If particularly if they have a
close connection without having to go in
the small boats I just want to unpick
this a bit um for people who might not
be familiar with the phrase safe and
legal reads because the situation as it
stands is that for many countries
including places like Sudan for example
that's been used there aren't any ways
for people to legally claim asylum in
the UK right the there are but they're
really difficult so if you come from
Hong Kong or Ukraine they've been the
resettlement schemes and we've taken
over 300 000 people from those two areas
and will take a lot more particularly
from Hong Kong if you're part of the
Syria scheme we took on 24 25
000 um syrians and gave them safe
passage and brought to the uh to the UK
and then there's the Afghanistan scheme
as well the trouble is with the
Afghanistan scheme where we airlifted I
think at the time about 15 000 people
legally from Kabul Airport in a hurry
something like 9 000 of them 18 months
later are still in hotels so it shows
the problem that how we not just bring
them to the UK safely but then can give
them full-time permanent accommodation
so it's not um it's not easy so there
are routes through family reunion and
through the unhcr the refugee agency but
they're really difficult to get on so
what we want is to make sure we have got
proper safe legal routes widely
advertised much more accessible and
these will be additional to what we've
got now and that's what the government
has agreed so the example that I
challenge the home sector with
notoriously is a months ago what if I'm
a 16 year old orphan from an East
African country with a relative legally
in the UK how would I get to the UK
safely and legally which she's slightly
struggle to answer that hypothetical
situation became a reality this week
with Sudan that 16 year old is actually
happening um now so we need to make sure
that we can pass that 16 year old
Sudanese test for somebody who clearly
isn't Simon Seeker clearly escaping
danger has a connection with the UK if
they've got a relative here so it has a
case to apply for Asylum to the UK
that's the sort of person we need and I
think most people would agree because
that we have a duty to because right now
the 16 year old from Sudan can't can't
get here if they had a relative that can
go through quite an elaborate process
they might stand a chance if they made
it to a unhcr refugee camp or something
like that then they might be able to
what we need to do as we've done in the
past we've done it very successfully in
the in the past is expand family reunion
schemes and say to the unhcr we are
prepared to take on from Sudan or
whatever X number of um of genuine
refugees please go and identify for them
and we'll arrange them to come over here
and that's the sort of thing we're going
to get in the future now now our level
with you
when I wake up interview ministers they
say yes we're going to open more say
from legal routes yeah yeah yeah it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen not right
now we can't say what they are we can't
say how we're going to do it but it's
going to happen
do you actually believe them yes it's
got to happen so what the amendment that
I got through today says ideally what I
wanted it to to do is that when this
bill goes into law and all the tough
measures come in the safe and legal
routes are ready to kick into into
action I didn't get that because there's
a lot of work still to be done but what
the amendment does guarantee is that
within six months of the bill going
through the government will have had to
properly consult with local authorities
and others to see what we can take and
how we're going to accommodate them it's
not a case of bringing them here but how
are we going to look after those at
those people and what those safe and
legal routes are going to look like how
people will be able to access access
them uh and and get to the uh to the UK
and they will start next year and that's
a bit of a gap but actually it's a clear
undertaking that will now be on the face
of the bill and the government will be
beholden to and we'll make sure that
happens you'll make sure it happens how
you can do that you're going to be on
the case well if it if they don't
produce those details when the bill goes
to the House of Lords is going to get a
tough time in the House of Lords it's a
controversial bill it's necessarily
tough there are going to be many more
changes to it before it becomes law but
if people want safe and legal routes
this bill now offers it so there's got
to be a compromise in the in the laws
we've got more detail from the
government as to how they what they're
going to look like
in order to get it through the Lord so
these safe liquids can can start so I'm
confident we we're trusting ministers to
produce it they've said there's going to
be an annual vote in Parliament as to
how many refugees we can sustainably
um take on we want to do this but we
want to make sure we're taking on the
right people genuine refugees escaping
persecution Civil War Sudan uh who have
a connection with the UK and that's what
this does
Andrew Mitchell earlier said that the
government is testing the limits and his
words of international law I mean some
would say that they're breaking it
well okay so there's an issue about the
European convention and this problem
when we try and Deport people then at
the last minutes there is an interim
Junction produced under the echr by an
anonymous European
um judge and that's happened so many
times and that grounded the Rwanda
flights which hadn't started
um yet
those section 39 injunctions they used
to be called temporary
injunctions are not actually part of the
European convention they are an internal
process of the European convention
system
everybody Raves about the echr over the
last 10 years there are more than 400
convention rulings that have not been
complied with we are one of the best
compliers with convention rulings of I
think only nine outstanding rulings we
haven't complied with which includes
like things like giving votes to
prisoners which in Parliament we voted
against because I and most people don't
actually believe in in Spain I think the
figure is something like 61 percent of
those major monies not being complied
with initially it's 58 France Germany is
very high people you can choose that's
not how
what I'm saying is we have only not
complied with a very small number lots
of value European countries have not
complied with a very large number but
we're the ones who are in the in the
frame and the convention knows they've
got to change their methods as well we
are out of time always interesting to
talk to you thank you very much for
being on the program
you're watching the take live in
Westminster up next we're going to be
taking a look at the gambling white
paper that is out tomorrow and expected
to propose tightening regulations
[Music]
a lot of action going on I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
this is what makes a job so fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Mark Stone and I'm Sky's
correspondent based here in Washington
DC
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
cool thing you know his memories is all
gone
in almost every corner this town has
been completely destroyed by the fire
I've witnessed a remarkable passion for
politics here but the anger too we have
to get Trump out of the White House is
this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics
important it's at the heart of the issue
I I get that that's where the media
likes to go it's not it's where many of
the people we've talked to here like to
go I report on the biggest stories from
around the world
this is a town that is effectively
encircled by the Russians
you say it's all fabrication what's
happening in butcher
destroyed my nation
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our planet
I can hear now quite a few explosions in
the distance here in Jerusalem a very
violent series of confrontations here
what do you think of Isis anybody here
know the truth of Isis
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so welcome back live to Westminster you
are watching the take now a government
white paper on changes to the regulation
of the gambling industry is tomorrow but
there are some real and serious concerns
from campaigners about the closeness of
the relationship between MPS and the
gambling industry our political
correspondent Liz Bates has been taking
a look
it was first promised in December 2020
by the then culture secretary Oliver
Dowden a year later his replacement
Nadine Doris said the gambling white
paper was coming she was reshuffled and
it was delayed last April we were told
it was a matter of weeks but then Boris
Johnson's Premiership collapsed and it
was delayed again now after two and a
half years five delays three prime
ministers four culture secretaries six
gambling ministers finally the white
paper will be published tomorrow by the
latest culture secretary Lucy Fraser
in that time the gambling industry has
been busy pouring cash into politics and
scan uses Westminster accounts tool
allows us to show you just how much
gambling gaming racing companies have
splashed out over 200 000 pounds on
donations to MPS this Parliament almost
all of that in the form of tickets to
Big sporting events and hospitality
the top Source lobbying firmed the
betting and gaming Council who gifted
over 90 grand in freebies to more than
40 MPS its CEO is Michael Duggar former
labor Minister who is well connected in
Westminster the MP who's made the most
is conservative Lawrence Robertson who
has had 33 and a half thousand pounds in
Hospitality on top of almost sixty
thousand pounds for being an advisor
it could be a lot more though as any
gift less than 300 pounds doesn't have
to be declared and Tori MP Scott Benton
who was secretly filmed by the Times
newspaper seemed to suggest the system
is open to abuse he said without saying
too much you'd be amazed at the number
of times I've been to the races and the
ticket comes to 295 pounds
tomorrow we'll find out whether all this
has paid off we expect a new mandatory
levy on industry profits and state
limits on slot machines and new rules to
slow down online casino games more
controversial measures though could go
to consultation and the government after
all this could still run out of time
lots of scrutiny there on the gambling
industry as Liz Bates was saying
remember of course you can use our own
Westminster accounts tool to find out
exactly how much MPS have been getting
paid or getting donations for as well
through Industries like the camping
industry so definitely worth checking
out well it's been a busy day in
Westminster to say the least at the
minute it feels like everything is
slightly heightened here to be honest
ahead of those all-important local
elections both British Scenic and
kierstama know that it's going to be
seen as a test of their leadership who
is going to come out top it's a game of
expectation management as always with
these things but also geographical too
only in England the election's taking
place but of course that's where some of
the decisive seats could be held to well
that's it for the take we'll be back
next week and every week 9 p.m Wednesday
nights next up it is God news at 10.
thanks a lot for watching
foreign
[Music]